[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to the lobby
GameSpot's weekly video game hangout
here in San Francisco I'm your host Mike
McCarty here's always a peep round
hey Rob Hanley what song and
callyblackie hello it's a busy week it's
kind of the first of those crazy weeks
that we're getting into with Mario
Assassin's Creed Wolfenstein - stranger
things - if you're more into the
entertainment side of things that starts
Friday but we've been playing all three
of those games I just mentioned and
we've been talking about Bach extensive
some semi extensively about two of them
can't really talk fully about any of
them unfortunately but we've been
playing a lot of them so we gotta got a
full show today Jake Decker's gonna come
on later talk Assassin's Creed he played
through the whole thing last week with
Alessandro with a review event we can't
again give like review opinions but we
could talk about more of the game and
we've all been busy so we're gonna have
Jake come on and Kelly I know you're
doing destiny to PC and Wolfenstein
right now to pcs done we'll be talking
about that more throw the show destiny -
on PC Wolfenstein - the new Colossus
Assassin's Creed origins and we're gonna
touch on Fire Emblem warriors but the
bulk of the show will go elsewhere as
always we have the twitch and YouTube
chats up we'll have a giveaway which
I'll announce later on the show and I
wanna get to some news items first kind
of speed through it cuz we're all busy
this week we talked a lot about loot
crate's and microtransactions
there's be a responded to battlefield
battlefront two criticisms they said the
pay2win criticisms are hard to dodge
they can respond after the beta first
off the art director from EA motive who
was doing the battlefront Sue's campaign
Chris Matthews said right now there have
been games that exploit players and
everybody games that have done it in
better ways the response is not annoying
because we love the fans think it's good
to know we're gamers and we're trying to
make something that's super compelling
that everybody's going to enjoy but you
know it's understandable that's that's
the very non answer we're trying to make
a game it's gonna make us a lot of money
so then dice published on their blog
they address some of the
microtransaction related concerns saying
the complete system was not in the beta
and will continue be tuned overtime aka
the next two weeks until the game comes
out or land post release I'm assuming as
a balance goal we're working towards
having the most powerful items in the
game only erna Bolivia in-game
achievements
so yeah we'll have more to say on that
come November mid-november when the game
releases I believe 17 that come on I
think so yeah your answer I believe will
will be starting to review event for
that in a week or two probably kind of
getting ahead of the curve a couple days
so ei early access will have the game on
November 9th okay and I'm not sure if
that means it'll be this similar like
ten hours from you know I think the last
time biggie a game came out we'll see
yeah I should have either myself or
Alessandra sometime with the game before
that suite just multiplayer though cool
also Xbox ones first original Xbox games
are backward compatible as of now Phil
Spencer announced it at e3 there's a
whole slew of them I'll go through
several of them crimson skies high road
to revenge what you two or fans of yes
well this is a busy week but hopefully
we get the try out some of these Ninja
Gaiden Black Prince of Persia sands of
time which is uh which is a good game
Psychonauts which I still have not ever
played I've also never played yeah maybe
every time like they rerelease it I'd
say this is kind of maybe my excuse to
play it
yeah Red Faction to Sid Meier's pirates
dead to rights black which they just
showed briefly before that was like love
black yeah it was the destructible
environment that was such an impressive
game when it came out was that that was
one of the real games to do destructible
that was both those that was traits big
selling point yeah version two is wild
making tunnels and stuff yeah are you
nothing in the barmageddon' no red
factory she runs to Mars you can like
terraform the land yeah I believe and
you're you're literally terrifying no I
think it's first-person maybe yeah ready
to but it but then of course yeah black
was really good and then Star Wars and I
steal Republic it's also yeah and so you
can play that once again and if you can
go online
Microsoft has some like comparative
screenshots things look really good
they're handled really well I'm really
happy what Microsoft is doing with this
yeah um it's a sort of thing that makes
me think twice about having an Xbox
setup yeah Xbox one X hopefully we are
getting one
outlets are getting them in the next in
a few days but I think reviews will be
up next week for the console itself the
console upgrade as it work and it goes
on sale what the seventh or something
like that yeah soon are you getting one
you know no there's a lot of money
I can't afford all that money 500 u.s.
American dollar e-news yeah which is
what like $4.99 without tax I don't know
are you guys you know I've been using my
xbox a lot lately actually even within
two in South Park I both have on xbox
yeah like oh we're fortunate to get
codes and then I kind of just cleaned
out the Xbox codes afterward didn't I
don't know let's go back to last week to
pop yourself did a good job of updating
definitely good Xbox is not as painful
to navigate at all
quite the opposite now yeah we talked
about it last week two weeks ago it was
last week greatest we talked about a lot
of things last week yeah it and then I
go in cup head I've been playing that on
xbox - so it's been getting some love
speaking of Xbox games Pub G which will
be released on Xbox one at some point I
think before the end of the year
pugsy physical release confirmed for
Xbox one it's getting the disc treatment
according to Patrick former disc
treatment yes
it's been so they obviously are doing
super well on PC they don't have an
exact release date yet but the new math
2017 the games Twitter account has just
revealed that you'll be able to buy a
physical version of the game I'll get it
even though I probably never open it or
use it but it's still it's surpassed two
million concurrent players last week on
earlier this month on Steam and it
peaked at nearly 2.2 million according
to Steam stats and we have a bunch of
like beginners tip if you want to get
into the game because it's still very
relevant we are I've been playing a lot
more lately the desert map should be out
semi soon which is good because well I
thought it was desert no that's cop had
desert map that'd be a really good pub G
arena this he's guys he's holed up at
the cupcake let's get him depressed
animals do and they have nothing left to
do in life to look forward to guys its
what's banana split and head over the
power Peter Brown you like to just do
I liked injustice to a lot is a pretty
cool fighting game I still play it from
time to time jump I'll be uh I'll say hi
to my boy green arrow Oliver Twist I
almost had stone Oliver Queen but it's
coming to steam later this year I'm not
just bringing this up for no reason
does it come with us later this fall no
release date yet but it'll be out
there's my boy what about mod support oh
don't let me to check that out
yeah there's no specific dates but open
beta will arrive on October 25th which
is today open beta for injustice to
Okada's that'd be on PC here we go it's
it's gonna be from the polish studio Q
LOC who also ported Mortal Kombat X owl
to pc lock so yeah exile had some weird
PC issues at launch
well that's hopefully I'm singing that
out no no I'm not I'm not saying that
that bodes ill for this game I'm just
saying hopefully they'd figure that
stuff out before we get into the bulk of
the show I want to ask you guys we've
talked about us before but now that it's
upon us this is kind of a difficult
question because we've all been playing
the games already but well how do you
plan to spend October 27th which is
super mario odyssey Wolfenstein - the
new Colossus Assassin's Creed origins
and stranger things season - Pete what
do you what's your priority pretend you
haven't beat Mario already or play a lot
of it mm I think pretend I haven't I'm
just kidding just what is your plan for
speak words I think my time will be
spent between Wolfenstein 2 and stranger
things given that I have played a [ __ ]
ton of Mario yeah yes that sounds in
line with what I'm doing
plus more Mario for me robot you Rob you
played Mario a lot - yeah I still plan
on playing more of it I think I like to
think about Netflix and you know zoning
out with like a switch so I think that's
a good call I think Mario is the only
game you could do maybe sasnett's creed
but like Mario's on the game that like
you know doesn't have a dialogue you're
like like hardcore cinematics that you
can just play levels and watch stranger
things but I don't know stration things
you got to give it you know
percent you know I think boys you gotta
give up yeah well I'm saying is
definitely Wolfenstein right like
someone that's like most likely to be
like Mario I don't think much is gonna
be spoiled for you aside from specific
unlocks but Wolfenstein is story having
also condensed enough that a lot of
people have finish it probably Friday
said people gonna talk about Mario for
weeks
write about Wolfenstein for a week yeah
yeah right that's kind of like what we
were talking about for like reboot
prisoners or like features really which
one is more prescient right now and
we're like Mario is not gonna fade away
at all not the Wolfenstein is bad so I'm
saving the quality yeah yeah yeah I mean
like I'm obviously going to beat
Wolfenstein before then as I'm reviewing
it but if I if I hadn't been playing
Wolfenstein the same way mark you
haven't been playing Mario Peter I would
probably start there because that's I
think that's a game that's easily
spoiled and that is not one I want
spoiled how long is Walt insane I based
on what I have played and can say I'm
going to say it's probably upwards of 20
hours that's pretty long oh I would say
lower why was 75% I'm playing stealth
yeah I'll probably that lengthened i i
mean it's less frustrating for me yeah
we'll get to that
yeah it's a decent length game I'd say
it's comparable to a new order maybe a
little longer from what I've seen yeah
it was last actually a few months ago
but I remember what it was yeah we could
talk more about that game but yeah
Friday coming up there will be reviews
dropping for all three games tomorrow so
all over the place well Wolfenstein may
take some more time I'd be just like all
like other like Margaux's oh you got it
that's the embargo for the review yeah
for you think anybody's gonna hit that 4
a.m. though maybe maybe but like I could
be a game in a few hours but I'd like
that's the game writing it and then yeah
cutting the video review yeah
yeah before the weekend why but yes
tomorrow we will have Assassin's Creed
and Mario reviews going up at 6 a.m.
Pacific cool on GameSpot that comment
both of them are 6 a.m. Dan unless I'm
misremembering something GameSpot's
gonna be popping off yeah like I said we
gonna bring a gun later and talk more
about sanskrit origins cuz he's played
the entire thing he could talk about he
can't give like final opinions but he
can talk much more about it than I can
because I've only played like half an
hour not for lack of wanting to but just
time constraints busy yeah alright let's
get into one that I have not mentioned
at all until now Fire Emblem warriors
released last week kind of right on the
cusp of this busy part of the year and
we're right in the middle of it I guess
Kelly you like Musso games am I saying
that correctly yeah these are just kind
of like dynasty Warriors of dynasty
Warriors Fame very hack-and-slash larger
battlefields a lot of people that you're
killing we're so mean I don't know the
direct translation I don't know if there
is a direct equivalent in English but
it's you know like the mowing down
thousands of enemies in a level you're
kind of taking on objectives and
capturing forts and stuff like that I
will say if you were going to play a
game and watch a TV show you could
probably do that with firemen warriors
it's a lot less intensive because it's a
moose a game I mean that the thing about
them that I like is that you don't have
to think too hard it's just really
satisfying to kill all enemies and and
somebody who really likes Fire Emblem I
think there's yeah I mean they they
definitely have mechanics that like call
back to Fire Emblem like there is a pair
up thing which was introduced in
awakening I believe and so they they
have that and it creates like a new
cinematic that's just cool and
satisfying to watch I think some of it
is not as successful like I a obviously
it's a weird thing to translate a
turn-based strategy game into this kind
of game but can you be like can you be
like silica and all from Fire Emblem
echoes which is the
for animal game I played and I really
really liked it I actually don't know
what the full roster is I know there's
like certain ones that are missing I
think Roy or Ike is missing I can't
reach one right there are some iconic
characters that people are a little bit
sad to see that you know they aren't
there but there's gonna be DLC like
Hyrule warriors had like yeah gonna say
hi world war is another one that took
existing franchise adopted this I didn't
play Hyrule warriors at all like what
were you fighting in Hyrule warriors but
cobble I mean all sorts yeah obviously
like you said Kelly these games don't
seem like it would be made for this but
it makes sense I guess is an easy
property to adapt them to yeah it's cool
I mean I play dynasty warriors back in
the day not many of them know the first
game was literally a one-on-one fighting
game called dynasty on playstation like
fighting fighting like yes oh damn like
Soul Calibur yep and then it's just like
way different now Oh segue missing
I've enjoyed what I played of this and I
know I think Jake has played a lot more
than I have so it's sucks that he's
coming on later but I think he also has
been enjoying it
yeah like I said I just kind of recently
got into Fire Emblem with echoes I got
fates and awakening yeah after playing
that and actually echoes probably in my
top 10 for the year I'd say I like that
game a ton it makes sense I like
strategy games turn-based kind of in the
vein of a certain alien game that I like
but anyway did you from what you played
is good entry on the switch something
more to just kind of pass the time
because there's nothing else coming out
for the swish there's nothing else to
play on your switch I do think like if
you are looking for something that's
going to just be like I'm relaxing in
front of some junk food TV I'm gonna
watch my hunter and and play something
idle that's probably what I would
recommend this for I mean that's what
that's why I personally play these kinds
of games is just kind of a cathartic
like I'm just like cleaning up some
enemies and not thinking too hard really
sweeping yeah you got a broom you got a
dustpan yeah yeah but obviously like I I
think it's got some tough competition
coming up so it's I I wouldn't be like
oh yeah go get this and not play other
games coming to this which would you
even call these games like people are
mentioning like would you call these
games a power fantasy or is it even not
going that far
cuz I this just looks like the game
itself is just I'm stepping aside for
you I don't think it's a power fantasy I
think it's I mean Peter said it like
you're literally just sweeping it's like
it's just overcoming like crazy I know
you're just like you're literally just
like cleaning up a they look like ants
like yours cleaning up a mess basically
yeah the ants are smarter stronger
what is this it's true they can carry
like a lot like two ants can carry a car
if I can carry an ant that makes me
strong as [ __ ] right yes it can fight me
anytime so this is out on switch as of
last week Friday I believe yeah I know
Ben Jenkins a fan of like Musso games
he's been playing a little bit or was
playing a little bit I think Jake
touched it a little bit just because of
the Fire Emblem IP which is probably the
main reason I would go to it I I'll be
honest nothing against a game I'll never
play this I don't think I'll ever find
time to play it especially or just a bad
time I would say for this to come out
who knows if this is someone's nishan
and go for it cool destiny to has been
on console since early September now
it's on PC as of yesterday
two days ago yes yes you played quite a
lot of it before that your review and
then you played more PC just to update
the review yeah just to kind of test out
like the performance on PC and and stuff
like that yeah so Kelly what is a my
main question is is it worth returning
to on PC if like you've already like
again there's a few people in the office
here I guess everyone here myself
excluded have played a lot of it do you
think it's worth going back to on PC now
that it's on the new platform and maybe
like a new audience coming in I was
thinking about that a lot actually
because one of the things people are
talking about with destiny too is the
like well what's the longevity the
player base has been dipping not like to
an alarming degree or anything I think
it like dip from 3.2 million to like um
1.5 million or something like that it
decreased by like 50% in a few weeks
after launch which again
still the percentage is alarming but the
number I mean it's like still but still
half of pub G no yes not it's no law
breakers you know so one of the two
people that play that uh yeah so I I
mean I played like a maybe two three
hours when I was testing this system
story and some crucible and I will say I
am not cut out for this kind of game on
PC I'm just not I this is the kind of
game I play with dual analog and I so I
will not be playing a ton on on PC
myself so does that apply to only
multiplayer right yes I didn't
experience like any problems with the
PvE like the PvE felt the same the
shooting feels great and it's honestly
like you can tell that like obviously
the game that was made from the ground
up for console can have some problems
coming to PC and I didn't encounter any
of those things the aiming is smooth I
did have to tweak the hotkeys right yeah
I tweaked my key binding I didn't like
where Crouch was because I like to run
slide and I tweaked the view sensitivity
the aim sensitivity so there's a couple
things but like those options are there
it has the full expected graphics and
key binding settings that you would want
and so all of that worked really well
for me so weird to think of destiny on
PC because when I think of destiny I
think perfect console controls like
mechanically I would say this is the
closest a shooter has been to perfect as
far as the actual aiming mechanics and
movement so I mean from everything
everybody saying it feels good on PC
mouse and keyboard but it's still just
to me seems so out of place I know a lot
of people right I know a lot of people
really prefer PC as a platform
there are games that I definitely prefer
to play on PC and this is overwatch like
like that's the thing is I I was like I
have done fine and overwatch I haven't
played in a long time but back when I
did play it wasn't like I struggled a
lot because I'm so used to dual analog
shooters but this is not the kind of
it's like twitchy like low time to kill
shooters that I just don't do like
farewell with
on PC so it's not fair to say because I
did play like quake back in well anyway
that's beside the point
um you probably weren't a counter-strike
fan if that's the case right no I'm not
played counter-strike I'm so bad at PvP
on console the mouse and keyboard
opportunity for me is the reason that
I'm gonna play destiny 2 on PC for a bit
so you have the opposite thing for
vegetables purposes for crew I mean well
well just in general like I think you
guys made valid points like it shooting
does feel really good on console but you
know when I think of games like
titanfall 2 and just for example like I
don't I don't think destiny is in a
league of its own necessarily in that
regard and always I just I just what I'm
aiming on consoles it doesn't know how
many times I tweak the settings it's
like if only I had a mouse that [ __ ]
wouldn't have killed me right you know
because I get freaked out and like my
analog stick like I don't know how to
manage that but I don't know I'm Plus
this game can look really good as well
so just to sort of see it like
unfettered by console limitations yeah
you know I could I I see that comment
like or that point like yeah I think
about console first-person shooters
where it's like there's a there's or
just with the controller there's an
amount of patience you have to have I
think with like precision you know what
I mean where it's like you can't just
twitch your way with it with like an aim
for aiming on like headshots right like
it's just it's like yeah but so many
it's a you're doing more like strafing
with movement I don't I mean like expect
you're gonna miss a few shots I do a lot
more strafing I do a lot more melee
right kills
it's just thinking about like what games
as well I prefer with PC is for the most
part it's first-person but like I think
about like your exploration but like
loot gathering like something like
fallout is something or I know you can
sign even it's like having a mouse
cursor to go yeah exactly like that type
of stuff like whenever I'm playing
console I'm like grinding my teeth
because I know I can be I can be quicker
with it with a PC I'm playing
Wolfenstein right now well Wolfenstein
doesn't have that exact problem but I
know Shawn Luke's been playing
Wolfenstein 2 on PC and I kind of want
to
but I do kind of want to play mouse and
keyboard just to have that freedom of
movement
hey I do think just before we finish
with destiny I will say like I have the
Pete the console muscle memory with
destiny I played obviously a ton on ps4
so the transition I think was just like
I'm like oh no you know I'm not gonna go
back to this but I don't learn things so
yeah I had to unlearn and relearn right
but I think like it's it's definitely
like there's an untapped player base
that didn't get to play those PC players
and I am interested to see how that
affects the like continued like the
longevity of the player base like I said
the vs. PC the a lot of like really high
level players are saying like the
endgame is not completely there yeah and
so I'm just interested to see the
comparison between like a the console
player base in a month and the PC player
base yeah that's the question I know you
look at games that are thriving kind of
I know like fortnight's doing really
well obviously pub G is the pinnacle of
concurrent users right now what did I
say it peaked at 2.2 million and destiny
I don't even know honestly what these
numbers are compared to the first game
is that right after its launch I think
this game is in better shape than the
first game was this X weeks after its
launched what like six now definitely a
better base then yeah even the first
game after all its expansions I think
yeah I mean you look at like a line
graph of its player base in it again
it's dropped for whatever use had 3.2
million 21.4 yeah 50% I made it up to
illustrate but it's something around
that and that's most games do that but
destiny maybe not to that exact number
but destiny is obviously games as
service kind of platform so the vitality
the game in the long run is a very
important part of its design so I'm
curious if PC will bolster it obviously
this is a busy time of year but I wonder
if like the games that are really using
actually even compete with it right PC
and the the DLC the whatever Osiris I
can't remember the name now tears no the
trials a nine curse of the stars travels
lips iris know the deal there's a cyrus
theme DLC expansion sorry the when they
announced gotcha um that one I am
excited
I'm interested to see how that will
affect people coming back as well yeah
people don't seem I know Eric tey is
pretty being probably our main destiny
expert he was pretty pissed about iron
banner loot drops dude is not worth it
did you play a lot of it it was really
disappointing yeah I did play a lot of
it for me the biggest problem wasn't
necessarily I didn't get the armor that
I wanted as fast as I did but it was
just I was playing modes and I'd played
elsewhere and I was fixed into one type
of mode and it was like the act of
grinding and this manner is boring to me
I can get I can get cool [ __ ] anywhere
in destiny yeah
binding with a variety of activities
we've talked about it briefly to iron
banner used to be kind of the place to
show off what you've earned now it's
just it's kind of a level playing field
yeah because they got rid of the or they
didn't have I'm not raising this
properly the old iron banner disregarded
level or didn't disregard level
advantages this one does yeah your light
and your equipment itself was taken into
account this is like honestly I would
like the competitive crucible modes so
much more if there wasn't countdown I
hate countdown with a passion I think it
sucks
it's a bad mode if they wanted to be
more like counter-strike should've done
it better
I don't like it don't like it survival's
way better it sucks
how do you actually feel though I like
to Peter's point destiny has a lot more
variety and things you can do to grind
and so the expectation of iron banner
being the pinnacle and not getting that
was disappointing I wonder if they're
going to rectify that with the expansion
but we'll see cool is the rate and
everything available for PC or is that
yeah I think well I think they're doing
what the raid is a week last I heard the
raid is a week after so the same as
console and then after that it'll start
syncing up with console on the road um
and yeah I didn't get far enough like I
didn't unlock like the nightfall or
anything in my story mode player I
unlocked crucible and I tested out
matchmaking and stuff which by the way
is fine there were no problems and so
I'm I'm not sure if there was it was the
same night foal I think somebody did
verify that I don't know somebody like
like I don't think it was tape
sync up all the events right for how
long after will epi apologies if you
already said this Oh like a when last I
heard it would be like a week
I think micro Joe on our la la office in
our LA office plays a lot of destiny
that dude he's he had the deets
on the schedule cool yeah we have more
in depth impressions from Michel Higham
who plays a lot of PC games he went up
to Bellevue to Bungie to play this yeah
if you want like spec information yes
want to hear opinion from a calculator
well like he has like suggested builds
and like suggested like settings for
different PC builds and stuff like that
which is really helpful more in-depth
than what I would do for a review so the
coverage types complement each other hmm
final question and you touched on this a
lot but I want to see if like we can get
deeper into it right before we end do
you think like how is destiny two's kind
of longevity at this point as compared
to destiny ones at this point do you
think it's more vital than destiny one
was at this point you think they've iron
out way more the kinks or I think it's
kind of disheartening like the first
game seemed to be in its endgame um I'm
not personally disheartened one of the
things I like about destiny too is that
I don't feel like I'm behind if I don't
play for a week
whereas with destiny one like I like if
I didn't play for a little while I'd be
like well there's I can't play with my
friends anymore cuz they're all ahead of
me and there's just nothing I can do and
getting to a light level that's gonna
complement that is gonna take twenty
hours of grinding strikes um and I
didn't like that at all this one I think
destiny to I think needs to they need to
continue building upon it to get that
same level of like really deep endgame
stuff that I think the like core players
like the suit like the the Eric tase of
the world maxing yeah like all that
stuff I think that they could flush that
out more but I think they have a much
stronger foundation thank you cool so
that's available now on PC if you want
to go play that if you have not picked
up already but unfortunately we do have
to move on will consign to the new
Colossus we can talk about what the
first five chapters or something
yeah I don't know chapter numbers but
yeah yeah up to area 52 which has been
shown in trailers inglourious basterds
desk section will avoid spoilers but we
can talk about broad strokes just how
the game is faring so far I think in the
office I'm the farthest I believe me you
Nick and John Luke have been playing I
know Nick or - Nick was playing a lot
last night yeah I think Nick and I are
about the same I think you're the
farthest and then John Luke was playing
on PC which he got a little later so
he's a little bit behind yeah
in general this game is I'm liking a lot
and I to speak to the first five
chapters I would say one I want to get
through my minor concerns first I think
I don't I went back to play a new the
new order to see if like this was a
problem then I have a tough time this
game is harder than I thought it would
be this games hard I think it's it's
balanced you're the most part you're
playing on Normal difficulty so there's
six difficulties and the default is
three of six
I think it's called bring him on yeah
bring him on is like the it's just the
description is like medium difficulty
for experienced yeah gamers or whatever
the phrasing is this game is hard like
that's my first takeaway from these
initial chapters there obviously are
ways that you can make it manageable and
for me that has been stealth takedowns
as you can see here they're brutal
I like I hit a nazi with a hatchet in
the balls and then oh yeah like I did
that take down the for the first time
and I was like oh my god this does not
pull any punches with the brutality of
killing Nazis which I'm not complaining
about I love that it's a hatchet - it's
such a like a I mean Patriot one of the
takedowns is cutting their legs off at
your knees and then they fall and then
you hatch them in the face or like in
through a helmet if they're wearing one
yeah it's a it's brutal but it's it
feels really good my problem I'm having
is I don't always know that I'm losing a
[ __ ] ton of health like they're hitting
me there's not a ton of feedback so I'll
look down to my armors
- and my health is at ten even realize
that but if you're the better you get at
this game the better you are at kind of
scavenging in between shooting yeah and
the nice thing is like I was talking to
Peter about this earlier like the I
think the auto-saving is a little
unforgiving at points there were times
where like I would autosave into a
section where I had ten health and like
no armor and I don't know I have to
restart the level I don't know how I'm
gonna get through this and the the cool
thing was that I actually did find a way
to get through it and I was able to
scavenge in the middle of a fight and
like I it was really satisfying to
overcome those odds on that the game had
set up for me but there also is manual
saving so you can be proactive and be
like alright I have full armor right now
I'm just safe and like if some machine
beast attacks me at least I'm prepared
for it
first game I want to say kind of had a
similar dependency I guess you could say
on like not dependency but like the fear
like I I know the situations I feel like
from the from new order I had the same
where it was just like yeah 10 health
and you're just like crying over a lack
of armor in the air that wasn't easy
yeah there are some old-school
sensibilities obviously the fact that
it's not just regenerating I mean it's
like health will regenerate in
increments of 10 but then stop yeah if
you're like if you are at like 12 it'll
it'll regen up to 20 yeah it's kind of
like the it'll do the like round up to
the highest ten yeah gube shoe riot a
friend of the show obviously you
probably heard of him before he is
asking how long it took to unlock or
open the skill tree there's not a perk
tree like there wasn't the first game if
the others there's perks but it's not
like the tree like the first game it's
not a tree yeah you but you do it's done
locks the same way as the first game in
that like you unlock perks by completing
certain objectives but yeah it doesn't
like well yeah there were certain ones
that were that had prerequisites and in
your order but I don't I haven't seen
any prereq like gated ones in this one
yet yeah but like obviously it's like oh
do a hundred stealth takedowns you're
not gonna get that right away
yeah what are some of the ones you've
unlocked so far based on your I I've
been doing them in the Baja are we doing
a lot of stuff so I have like
I have like faster movement in Crouch I
have like quieter movement I've been
going for like killing the guards before
they can broadcast the alarm the
commanders yeah the yes a commandant
this is the Eber commandos or whatever
they're called that one I think unlocks
another like I think higher speed and
Crouch again they're all automatic
though you it's you don't have to like I
would call it a tree right passive or
not passive like some of them are like
active skills but it's like it's a tree
in that you have something to work for
but it's not like you go in there and
unlock them but you do as opposed to the
first game unlock weapon upgrades and
that one well it's not that's also not a
tree it's like a checklist almost but
you have to get upgrade parts you find
you just find them they're collectibles
throughout the maps and I would I would
recommend like I waited to use them
before I figured out like which guns I
like using the most but like armor piece
piercing rounds are so essential the
assault rifle right here that having a
scope on this makes it like a
semi-automatic it's also cool armor
piercing it it helps taking down the
robotic enemy or the heavily armored
enemies it's it's not it's unreal I know
John look I saw he did that too
yeah you have two assault rifles here
could you do that for one of them know
if you get an upgrade it's a problem so
but you could if you press left on the
d-pad right now you're left gun will put
the scope up and become semi-automatic
and then right controls the right one so
you can have if what you're asking it's
like the assault rifle on your right
hand could be on automatic mode and the
one your left hand could be on semiotic
cool yeah and that's another new thing
new order you can only do a will the
same weapon you can dual wield any
combination of weapons except for like
the heavy weapons yeah we're just really
useful because like if you need to take
down like normal like regular soldier
dudes and like heavily armored dudes
it's nice to have like an armor-piercing
round in one gun and like a faster clip
in the other it's it's uh it takes some
we talked about this during a preview
event or after a preview event that you
did it takes some getting used to
controlling each webinar as far as I've
got and I'm like 75% of the way through
the game or maybe even a little more
according to my save data l1 doesn't do
anything on the controller right now and
I kind of wish because like right now
you hold our
and then you're on the radial dial for
your right hand and you select which gun
and then to choose the gun on your left
hand you have to press left on the right
stick to get to the other radio dial and
then still like the one this is one of
the things we're talking about destiny
PC controls this is something I wish I
was doing I mean like I like playing
this game on ps4 but I do kind of wish I
had the mouse and keyboard specifically
because the weapon selection menu can be
a little tricky yeah I think it's an
improvement over new order new order it
was a little slippery and I felt like I
would miss my gun and then accidentally
like it quit my hand gun and it was
really annoying this I haven't
encountered that problem and I don't do
a wheel very often so it's not super I
don't do actually too often I'm like I
have like a silencer on my pistol and I
just go through and I try to take out
the Commons on yeah it's uh it's I'm
explaining this correctly so say you
want you have your dual wielding and you
want it on equip so you can just press
up on the d-pad and that will just if
you're dueling it'll go to the one that
it'll just equip the gun your right hand
or vice versa but if you want to
otherwise you want to unequipped your
left hand you'd have to go into the
radio dial select a weapon on the right
hand and then go left and then go to the
just the fist on the left one to put
your gun away it becomes second nature
after a while but because time doesn't
stop when you're doing this at least on
the difficulty I'm on I don't think it I
don't think it
I mean I'm yeah we're on the medium one
and it doesn't yeah you might on the
baby level that you have to literally
he's wearing up on it yeah you could
pause the game in a menu right and
didn't know it doesn't it stop time when
you're selecting weapons but I mean like
like actually pull up like any kind of
menu but it also people watch the game
but not to switch weapons
you can't acquit from the menu there's
only what you were saying that that's
the only way to just lock weapons is
with that dial yeah yeah or pressing
triangle to go to a previous weapon or
up to do a wheel yeah maybe I'm wrong I
feel like the first game you could like
pull up an actual menu and pause the
game and take your weapons I can't
remember not that I'm aware I don't
think nevermind I must think but to
answer good question those perks you can
start doing those right away if you're
doing stealth attacks or you can throw
the hatchet which I do a lot and then
pick up both throwing the hatchets yeah
and I say the hatchet you you use them
they are you'll just find them in like
pick them up in like a fire cases yeah
fire emergency but you're supposed to
destroy the radio thing I think he
missed it you can pick it you picked the
hatchet back up after you throw it yeah
yes yeah yeah it's just like there we've
talked a lot about gameplay I do want to
talk a little bit about Story 2 though
um
because and like with regard to gameplay
because one of the things that in the
first couple chapters I was noticing is
that there would be like a cutscene and
then like you would transition into like
the game models of the characters
talking and then there'd be game playing
so some of those transitions can be a
little jarring for me especially because
like there's you're really in like I
personally am very invested in this
story in these characters I really like
the characters in this series and then
just going like there was one section
that I I don't want to say because it
was spoilery but I just felt like I went
from cutscene to like gate like do the
input to get to activate the next part
of the cutscene and like that felt very
um I don't know just like antiquated to
me I didn't I didn't like that but I
will say that this is not a game that I
want to be completely like I don't want
to be so engrossed in this that I like
immerse and I forget what like how much
time has gone by because it's very
intense
yeah I mean the opening scene is like
really hard I teared up because we could
yeah this game the story story wise they
just detect some heavy [ __ ] in a few
ways but damn carrot like in terms of
writing characterization it's still
awesome if not better than all of the
carrot grace I love her grease is bad
I'm shown in trailers she's got the afro
she's she's like the leader of the
Manhattan resistance when you meet up
with them so freaking cool yeah she's a
super special ike boyfriend like first
lieutenant kind of man he's awesome he's
like yeah yeah yeah be a lawyer but then
he like got pissed off cuz he was
defending actually that might be part
later on but he used to be a lawyer yeah
I am I will say like there's I think as
opposed to new order in this game like
you can walk around and like over here
the knots
he's talking and there was like one
sequence where like an area 52 where
they're kind of like well you know why
why should they be violent against us
for having different views I just don't
get it violence is never a solution Carl
I like they had this whole conversation
and I'm like sneaking around and that's
a you chopping off his legs yeah that's
why I like stealth is because you can
overhear those things and you can also
talk to or like overhear conversations
uh in your like hub area and because the
character characterization is so good
there's certain characters whose
conversations I want to listen in on
yeah yeah was it old blood I remember
Chris waters was here he was laughing
his ass off me - and then like way and
he was playing old blood I believe and
he stumbled upon yeah through stealth -
to Nazis having an argument over grammar
it's there you said it's wrong like like
watching you talk about yeah so amazing
like it's so self-aware and yeah the
writing is it's I will say this and this
isn't spoilery but if we could talk past
the first five chapters and I think even
past where you are now I would be
talking very differently about the game
as a whole I agree this game changes in
several ways and that's I'll say that
but I do wait I can't wait to talk more
about the game as a whole because I'm
very I am really really holding back on
saying a lot of things but I will say
that um the game is very fun
I love the gameplay like I said I do you
can see he's got the doc ooh the arm
around huh I don't know I'm my yeah you
have to like there's more of a like yeah
like I I'm afraid yeah I'm afraid to say
except I'm in a bunch of sex if you know
from the first game he's in this again
you've seen the trailers but he he's
like he's got the that background and he
says we're much better than I do
obviously but it's it's it's weird
seeing played new order and then you
play doom another kind of like reboot of
a series and then you go back to this
and obviously doom is very much about
forward momentum and motion this can be
- but you also need to know when to take
cover in this game because if you're on
the open the whole time the enemy is
even on like the default difficulty are
very
smart they'll push you out of where you
are
we like three people writing you another
person they're all pretty accurate you
can't just like camp in one spot and
like just hope to take down all the
enemies because they will find you
yeah and they will attack you yeah I
just on your point about like going from
this to from doom to this I just I do I
do like like I feel the kind of class
more classic style of the gameplay in
some aspects and pairing that with the
like Nazis won World War two alternate
history like it's just it's really cool
I like the juxtaposition a lot I love
finding the newspaper clippings around
about certain battles in America like he
led the Florida coast landing it's kind
of cool seeing that well one of the
things that I loved about new order was
that the newspaper clippings would have
things that were like very obviously
like not at all settled like about
America after World War Two but just it
was they were palette swap for Germany
yeah and so like there's one about like
the dropping of the atom bomb on New
York yeah that is just like oh wow they
didn't they are being not being subtle
about the language here and I think I I
like that new Colossus was like still
carrying that with like literally the
the KKK isn't it
sorry shoot them shoot up yeah I was
telling Pete
obviously when that old marketing thing
came out last week and I said like
there's only one side if you're not to
get the [ __ ] out or ever but there
there's such prescient stuff in this
even like very early in a game like
first cut scene there's no way they
didn't like rewrite some of this
recently oh my god the first I don't
know where that Jesus no way they're
like that's like I know why that what do
you say hey what did you just say over
the speakers do the voice of God is
yelling at us okay I don't know what he
wants me to do if he's not gonna repeat
what he said there's no way that they
didn't rewrite some of this in the game
there it's very there's like a newspaper
clipping that once the embargo goes up I
want to share that's kind of really
funny
and timely but I won't talk more about
those but anyway it's it's uh y-you all
laughing what's happening right now we
gonna fail I'm making it because it's
like I don't know this there's and I
just said I'll share when the embargo
but it's not a spoiler it's just a 20
newspaper clippings treat yeah but it's
it's this games just games go so far in
the first five chapters I like it a lot
I think difficulty just kind of spiked
sometimes throws the pacing off a little
bit I don't know yeah and like I said I
think some of the cutscene - gameplay
transitions are a little old-fashioned
in style yeah yeah mm-hmm
but it's good though yeah I like the
story so far personally it gets me amped
the metal music kicks in and all the
right times and like I was gonna stick
it's like sixties rock but with metal
tinge it's pretty I liked the music in
new order more this almost feels like uh
like Wolfenstein music in the style of
doom almost and I not sure how to do
that it doom was great I mean I liked by
no means like a death metal fan but like
goddamn did it work well in that game
like the doom soundtrack I just I don't
know how well the metal works oh yeah so
this will be out Friday your review will
be up sometime before the end of the
week hopefully you would playing that
plugging away to dust throughout today
but that's pretty much any final
thoughts on wolf signed to the new
Colossus sequel from Machine games those
are all my thoughts yeah we'll talk more
about past the first five chapters past
that area 52 next week in a lobby and
you can keep an eye out for the review
I'm gonna force that cool all right
Kelly I'm gonna let you get back to
playing that and destiny and all the
things you're busy with go save the
world
yeah okay thank good as always we're
gonna bring Jake deck around to talk
Assassin's Creed origins yeah good luck
with the rest of Wolfenstein yes yes get
off this very tall chair yeah transition
just fall out of them I don't even try
it
oh yeah if you're just joining we're
getting into our last segment we're
gonna talk about it's has to be virgins
Jake Thakur's just gonna pretty much
come on he's taking really long but
we're gonna get him on here
Jake's please always office espy origins
we have been swapping people out lately
but busy time of the year so we're
trying to give people more time and
everything and yeah hey what's up Jake
not much just SAS ins Creed that's about
it for me yeah you've been working out
features where you went to the review
event last week with Alessandro they did
I'm not sure how much I can necessarily
talk about can't do like final yeah I
mean I don't think I can say exactly
what I think of it but I can definitely
answer a lot of questions that people
might have about it people are curious
about this game yeah like obviously the
big deal is a they took a year off after
syndicate finally took some rest from
the franchise which has been yearly
since FSS 72 was it when they became 303
was and I love the series up until 3 I
think that's where I started to falter
but then I also like Black Flag but not
for Assassin's Creed reasons but my main
question is again Alice hunters review
will be up sometime soon ish in the next
couple days but I want to talk to you
about someone who was beaten the game
played all of it or I didn't laid like
20 hours or something I didn't finish
the game unfortunately like we had to go
somewhere else to play it
oh yeah however I did I I think I
probably finished two-thirds of it maybe
a little bit more explored most of the
world which is by far the coolest thing
about this game yes is the setting I
mean northern Africa
yeah and that's always been a staple of
Assassin's Creed is the setting it's
always kind of taken the forefront of
the experience however just seeing Egypt
I think is so cool yeah you can before
going more to that you can go outside of
Egypt right isn't it other parts of
northern Africa as well cuz it's not
it's not it's like the Cleopatra Julius
Caesar era right you can go outside of
the bounds of Egypt correct I believe so
I mean the map is huge okay
the map the map is very big like I think
Alessandra who finished it even said
that he didn't the story didn't take him
everywhere yeah but I'm pretty sure you
can go outside of Egypt but I'm not
entirely sure
okay but yeah the map itself one thing
obviously you could see if you're
watching this live the you could see it
like a Skyrim esque compass up there
rather than the old mini-map on all the
other assassin's creed's which just
became littered with kind of menial
tasks left and right in question marks
and exclamation points and collectibles
and side quests that just ended up being
fetch quest but how does that feel in
this game as far as exploring does it
feel like it's living up to what Ubisoft
has been saying that they're trying to
focus more on exploration or encouraging
you to explore rather than just going to
the next Waypoint yeah I would say so
I particularly really like that compass
up there I think it does do a good job
of kind of keeping your eyes focused on
what's around you rather than what's in
the corner yeah and seeing the question
marks up there is definitely enticing if
you get near something like ah wonder
what this is I'll go check it out
however it's not for some reason it's
not it's it's it's not as enticing to
explore as it was in Skyrim for me at
least like it wasn't like ooh I wonder
what this is I'm gonna go check this out
kind of when I got on a path or when I
had an objective I looked to see where
it was and just headed in that direction
I wasn't always like oh I'm deviating
from the path I guess you could say yeah
and that's kind of there also adding to
the combat this game usually it's like a
tack counter kind of contextual this
game they went more like actually active
you could dodge and there's a light
attack and there's a I mean I played a
little bit of it it's a block light
attack power the heavy attack shield
break or whatever you want to say how
does that all feel within like like I
know you played it in review events
before or sorry preview events but how
does it feel overall like as you're
maybe upgrading Biak your character and
everything does actually feel like the
combat is I'm more like a bigger focus
of the game this time around or it still
feel kind of like an afterthought it it
feels like a bigger focus of the game
and it has moments where it is a lot of
fun mhm
like what I've been saying is in
controlled environments it's really cool
like if you're in a flat area you're not
overwhelmed being able to like you know
focus more on making contact with an
enemy kind of pulling the trigger when
you want to attack there's a lot more
involved and interesting however the the
camera is one example like if you're in
a tight tight quarters and you're
fighting someone it is
now damn it can be tough or if you're
being attacked by a lot of people and
and you're messing with the control
stick your your your lock-on will just
fly all over the screen right in
Alessandra saying a lot of times he
would just turn off his lock-on and that
would solve a lot of the issues which
you can't do however I think when you
turn off the lock on it feels even it
feels floaty mm-hmm so I don't
particularly like doing that but yeah in
close quarters it is it is very
difficult to look at what's going on
sorry it's the most capable camel I've
ever seen
I like that you're riding a camel yeah
that was a camel it's like the scene in
The Mummy when Brendan Fraser and I sir
all sprinting across the desert and they
win because the camels have better
stamina that's what I was thinking -
yeah you remember that Brendan Fraser I
forget someone it was it Ben pack from
Johnny bomb he just randomly tweeted
Brendan Fraser's battlegrounds the other
day hello I think I think I did see that
I liked it um what about byuk is he a
likable character from what you've
played yeah for Michael's the wrong well
no Michaels were reacting sucked from
unity yeah I don't know I didn't play
syndicate enough the evie frye and but
he got fry is that correct
camels blood is so blue v and jacob i
could be wrong i think it's Evie and
jacob cry but I didn't play syndicate
but I liked by X so far yeah night Magi
he's a Magi he he is very serious and at
first he comes across as serious oh when
I started playing I was like great we're
gonna have another very serious kind of
brooding assassin's creed card or
whatever yeah which he kind of is to an
extent but there are definitely moments
of lightheartedness like there's a
couple missions where they're like
children or whatever and he'll like I
don't know kind of play around with the
children it's kind of nice seeing a
little more depth to this character as
opposed to yeah Connor who's just kind
of brooding just a cold murderer who
never feels anything yeah I mean he's
still a cold murder so there's people
asking on Twitter so Tom Merritt earlier
today responding to me saying what new
features is Assassin's Creed offering
for fans who have become labor the
series that may draw them back in so
people that like it's not their first
Assassin's Creed like myself
any of the features that you mentioned
kind of or the additions or the revamps
what are there any better gonna bring in
veteran players who might have kind of
gotten tired and for syndicate like was
a two year break helpful I think the two
year break was helpful I think the
biggest thing for me at least is how
open the world is it and how it focuses
more on exploration rather than a sort
of hub area where you're completing
isolated missions instead you go to an
entirely new area just because you know
you've traveled over there you find some
missions just at your leisure you do
them maybe you get halfway through a
mission you don't like it you go to a
different one so I think that adds a lot
more player choice than we've seen in
previous games and I think that could
draw people back in I think the combat
is also fun in those serene it can be
frustrating but I think early on I think
fans will enjoy the new style of combat
stealth too like I mean still like as an
assassin can you still yeah there's
stealth I I don't think it's great to be
fair I never thought the stealth in
Assassin's Creed games are that great
now and I don't think this one is any
better I know how Alessandro and Matt
we're kind of saying it may not even be
quite as good and but I don't wanna
speak too much to what they thought of
it but I mean to me it seemed like just
Assassin's Creed combat you sneak behind
enemies and you stab them but I think
the biggest thing that might have people
interested is the loot system I know a
lot of people play rpgs and games like
this for loot and now as you play you
will be getting differently you'll be
leveling up byuk and it feels more like
a character progression in terms of
abilities and level rather than you know
you just get a new you know you get a
new piece of tech or something like that
it's a little bit more fleshed out I'd
say in terms of that it's the loot
system like well-designed like I mean
cuz shadow of war had a loot system
obviously that drew some controversy but
it felt tacked on and shadow of war does
it feel actually essential to the
experience here Tobiah I don't think it
feels tacked on it but it's not nearly
as in-depth as something like destiny or
Diablo because most of the weapons feel
the same it's not like destiny where you
get an exotic gun that feels completely
different from another exotic
right I mean you get a legendary axe and
it'll feel like all the other axes
except there is a perk to it always in
damage or something
yeah poison damage or you'll regain
health on every hit or something like
that hmm
okay but still just seeing like a gold
weapon drop you like oh I wonder what
this is and you click on it like it is
it is entertaining to see what you get
as you play like your your spear here is
glowing probably one of the perks you
also like yeah that and what's the point
of fighting hippos self defense because
they attacked people and kill them you
can get resources from right yeah lumber
can so it's it is very Ubisoft in this
sensor it's like oh you an upgrade your
gear go hunt so you go because a hippo
skin yeah get some hippos skin because
you know nothing you know nothing's
stronger than hippo skin on right yes
yeah alright is there a push you play
stuff a lot or is it just like any other
Ubisoft game it's just there and the
menus it seems like it's just there in
the menus I think while I was playing I
got like one or two you play
achievements actually no I don't think I
did an assassin's creed I'm thinking
maybe South Park is didn't tell her it
was yeah it was pretty heavy-handed in
the South Park okay I'm off the bat it
starts off and it's like yours please
Star Trek Online or Star Trek sure yeah
it's marketing but like no like you
start off in South Park and it's like
log into you play if you want to wear
this Assassin's Creed outfit and
whatever was I don't know and then yeah
you're getting a lot of prompts in South
Park but here here it's not as often
doesn't doesn't seem as bad to be honest
I don't think I saw any notifications
for you play or anything like that you
can go to the in-game store and I think
you can purchase points in order to
purchase different outfits and weapons
sure but when I was in there I already
had like or I think we were playing on
yeah I already had like 750 or something
like that and I don't know how I got him
but I did so it seems like there are
ways to get those points other ways than
paying but you know yeah still you can
pay to get that cool stuff if you want
do you're talking a little bit about
side quests stuff because yeah that's
something I want to say it pulled me
away from Assassin's Creed games was
getting that fatigue of like you know I
think I've done this
about 50 times and you know some of the
you know the outside sidequest
activities were very they felt little
cutting Pacey's can you can you vouch
for that here or is it less of it is it
still present would you say it's it's
still present but I would say less of it
yeah they're they they do a good job of
giving context to side mission okay
that's cool for the most part like you
end up you hit a point where you get
basically get gated to move on and you
have to do a lot of them and when I did
that I was like alright I don't really
care what this mission is about I just
want to get it done so I can get to the
next area mm-hmm or get to the next like
story beat sure but like there are
definitely missions that are far more
interesting than what I played in the
older Assassin's Creed games in terms of
side quests however when you do talk to
an NPC when you get something like this
it's really hard to pay attention to
what's going on just because it's like I
don't know the characters eyes are like
dead and lifeless and they're not I
don't know just it's not exactly pretty
to look at when you're in these little
conversations wasn't there also
something they were like pushing was
like all the NPC's have like how do you
say like set like time of day would like
waypoints schedules schedules and stuff
would was that noticeable or I mean I
stalk someone for like two hours
yeah when you get your bird I'm sweating
right now it's going on talking about
stalking people and you're getting
excited that's oh so here's the bird
right now but the bird you can look at
enemies and it'll say what they're doing
actually I may not have oh yeah talking
so you can kind of see like alright he's
I don't know eating or something like
that pooping I thinking like gotcha now
is it now is the time to kill him
because he's pooping totally but I mean
you can completely ignore those and you
won't notice the difference like I like
it was more the thing ride flies and I'm
like I he's he's distracted I guess now
is the time to kill him as opposed to
some other time but I'd still kill him
anyway because it was the objective yeah
is there no multiplayer this time around
no multiplayer there who there there
there is there's like a connectedness to
it I don't know how much I can talk
about it but it's not like you're
actually facing off against other
players mm-hmm cool so this is out
tomorrow October 27th alongside Super
Mario - Friday right
all right today's Wednesday sorry
October 27th Friday alongside Super
Mario Odyssey and Wolfenstein 2 new
Colossus review embargo you said it's
4:00 a.m. tomorrow
Pacific 6 a.m. I believe sometime early
tomorrow morning no one's gonna be
always same time is Mario yes okay yes
and all Sandro is reviewing that that'll
be up on GameSpot sometime tomorrow Jake
thanks for coming on talking about it
that's pretty much your show so big day
Friday we'll have stuff coming out
between reviews and features guides kind
of we've got Joey's working on a pretty
cool project today I don't know how much
we should talk about we're interviewing
a developer of a recent game that we're
pretty excited to talk to you about
they're coming into the studio anything
else going on this week streams we're
gonna be streaming Wolfenstein - any
more code yesterday tomorrow worse Peter
and I are gonna be streaming well I
don't think six o'clock thanks I'm
a-gonna ween that's not even Oh select
your player that's the one I was really
good that's more Friday maybe I think
maybe what 9:00 tomorrow morning Pacific
time GameSpot YouTube - it happening
it'll be super mario odyssey you're
switching characters left and right
that'll be happening sometime in the
morning on our stream channels on
YouTube and twitch and GameSpot yeah
busy rest of the week we'll be helping
you out of GameSpot be getting some
stuff reboot is about Wolfenstein this
weekend so I got to finish that today
before I start writing that anything
else I think we covered everything it's
got a giveaway I can get in to watch
guys do that oh yeah oh my god all right
giveaway destiny to collector's edition
for PC this is us only apologies to
people out
there we have an unboxing for this mean
Jake did one you get some weird stuff
actually definitely there's a portable
solar powered phone charger there's a
tin foil blanket yeah what are the side
ones I call this if you're not watching
this then there's a solar blanket
there's some some emblems there's an art
book there's a this really really like
post-apocalyptic looking backpack but
anyway and then the expansion pack for
the next two expansions that's for the
ones they announced so far that might be
all the ones are doing postcard images
it's us only again apologies to people
outside that winner is gonna be picked
by 5:00 p.m. Pacific tonight so Oh hurry
up go follow game spot on Twitter if you
don't already and then retweet said
tweet about this giveaway which she will
be putting up momentarily and in the
twitch chat for their if your youtube
again just go to Twitter and retweet
that one random winner will be picked to
have a destiny to collector's edition
for PC and again if you want to go watch
the unboxing for it on I think we did
ps4 or Xbox a console unboxing you can
go watch that it's a good time yeah
sweet that's it it's pretty much the
show Jake thanks for coming on thanks a
lot
I know the last time was in the lobby I
said like a lot and take counted you
today interrupted earlier and then when
I tried to hear what he said he just
went quiet made us look really done so
yeah if you look real because I've
learned better that's our show thank you
everybody in the back you John Luke
Richard Eric as always and thank you
everybody for joining Ryan Schubert
thank you for moderating the YouTube
chat then Janko is in there as well as
always thank you for joining on YouTube
twitch and GameSpot we will be back next
week to talk about super mario odyssey
more assassin's creed more Wolfenstein 2
and maybe I don't know we're getting
towards Call of Duty I don't know if the
embargo will be up called new world war
2 and then battlefront 2 is coming out
we'll be talking about all those in the
coming weeks stay tuned to game spot for
guides features reviews everything all
that good stuff around those games
thanks for joining we'll see you next
Wednesday at 11 a.m.
[Music]
you
you